hi
and welcome to today's session where
we'll be talking about the new
accelerator
optimized vm family targeting machine
learning and hpc workloads
my name is chris clement and i'm the
product manager of gpus
and i'm going to start talking about
what my goal is why i show up to work
it really comes down to helping you with
your application
some customers pick infrastructure as a
service to run their fleet
some paths or platforms of service or
manage service offerings
no matter what you pick the key to
success
is the right infrastructure performance
total cost of ownership reliability
security
so on and so forth so to that end
we want to make sure the best gpu
compute
is enabled on google cloud not only that
we want to make it easy to get started
easy to scale and easy to optimize
performance
but it's not just the infrastructure
it's all about your workload
it's about machine learning or rendering
or cuda compute
or hpc or visualization we want to make
sure
we have the right products to fit your
needs
so let's talk a little bit about that
and talk about how committed we are to
that goal
last year we were very proud to announce
that we were the first major cloud
to offer the t4 gpu this is a
very low cost compute option with great
performance for inference
visualization or a lot of scale out
compute
every day i'm staggered by the growth of
this product line
there's one customer who's an autonomous
vehicle
customer they do large-scale simulations
to ensure
that self-driving cars are safe on the
road
using the t4 gpus on the other side of
the spectrum
let's talk about the best performance
historically we've had
the k80 and p100 v100
new products all the time and continuing
on that
last month i'm super proud to announce
that we're the first cloud to offer the
a100 gpu
you can come and get it today sign up
for the alpha and get access right away
not only that i'm proud to say that we
go up to 16 of these gpus in a single vm
and we'll talk a little bit about that
later as you can see on the right of the
picture
these hdx boards and a100s from nvidia
there's eight of them on the board
a special envy link and it takes special
server hardware to house them
so google compute engine
infrastructure's a service on gcp
historically we've been one family shop
one product the end one
it was great because they serve all
workloads you can customize it to your
needs
the right cpu right memory the right
storage
optional in-server ssd network attack
storage
and you can add gpus as you want what
type of gpu how many gpus
very customizable we've continued that
family with the n2
and the n2d for intel and amd cpu
processing
but we might laughed and we went right
we went low cost
cost optimized e2 vms right for
customers looking for the best tco for
cpu-based compute
but then we had a suite of new vm
families targeting specific workloads
this is where we looked at the workload
we said what does this need to succeed
we built special hardware special
virtualization configuration
and that's what today's new accelerator
optimized a2vm family is about
let's talk a little bit more about that
before talking about our family let's
talk about the key component of the a2vm
which is the new nvidia a100 gpu that
they just announced
this is a generational leap of
performance over the current v100 up to
20x speeds
floating.64 precision over
2x speed improvement this is used for
scientific computing
hpc workloads that you really need high
accuracy
fp32 kind of the de facto ml training
out of the box you turn it on
make it go without any optimizations
here the a100 ampere technology the new
tf-32
really shines up to 10x speed
improvements or
20x speed achievements when you use
nvidia's optional sparsicity
feature fp16 again two
five percent increase in performance
roughly right and into eight precision
10 or 20x great for ml inference batch
so a lot of performance and it's going
to be just a very minor price increase
on v100
so it's going to have the best tco for
gpu powered computer clouds
a little more than tf32 tensor cores
we're getting far into how the data is
processed and stored here
but really there's two key things i want
to point out
tf32 versus fp32
today a lot of code that just points to
fp32 will out of the gate
switch over to tf32 and nvidia spent a
lot of time to make sure that
for that processing less data you get
much more performance
and for a lot of workloads it doesn't
matter because the ml model's prediction
how accurate the model actually is at
detecting a person
or doing a translation isn't really
impacted by the bet and you get better
performance also new on a100 is the
support for bfloat16
so four different models for ml training
that you could use here
and it's very flexible pick the one that
meets your workload
needs i'd like to talk about a new
feature
on the a100 the multi-instance gpu
i'm really excited this for two reasons
first
allows multiple applications at the same
time
to be on a single gpu you can create two
partitions
anywhere up to seven partitions and not
only does it allow you to create
or run multiple applications on a single
gpu it creates fault isolation
performance guarantees so that you don't
have to worry about
one app running into another
additionally a very common enterprise
focus buying mechanism is to commit to
long-term usage
like a three-year committed usage
discount on these new a2 vms that we're
about to talk about
but there's some risk to that the risk
is we've already told you we're going to
launch the best gpu hardware there is
so what if we launch some new hardware
before your commitments up
this multi-instance gpu feature in a
ways
future proofs your investment you might
run a single workload for ml training on
full gpus
on one gpu 8 16 whatever for years
but maybe your business changes right
maybe you want to run
inference because you've done the
research on the training already
so you switch to these multi instance
gpus and you run
different workloads on it so it's
dynamic
it's future proof and it also increases
overall efficiency
of your infrastructure
now i am not a data scientist so i'm
just going to give you a high level
overview of sparcicity
but it turns out you don't need to
process every single data point
in every single calculation in an ai
neural network
so as the graph shows just doesn't do it
but by just not doing some again
doesn't impact accuracy of the models
you get a 2x speed improvement
nvidia is going to include some software
and some features that make this easy to
implement
and you can judge with yourself whether
or not to turn this on based on your
needs of accuracy
so all together a lot of improvement in
a100 gpu
so let's pivot and talk about our a2vm
family
so again we started with the ml workload
we started with hpc
and we figured out what does it need so
the first thing that got us excited
about the a100 gpu was the 40 gigabits
of memory
this is really needed because of ml
models are getting
more innovative which means more data
same thing with hbc or gpu powered
databases
right it's about data is getting bigger
and you need to store more of it and
process more of it
this is the largest gpu memory in this
family of v100 and p100 models
to date we offer 16 of these gpus in a
single
vm which means you can get a staggering
640 gigs of gpu memory
in a single host on top of that we take
two cascade lake cpus from intel with
96v vcpus
and up to 1.3 terabytes of memory this
is really important
because two reasons one some customers
come to us
whether it be financial or ml or science
and saying i just have a too big of a
data set
my gpu power i need might be variable i
need to have the vm the big memory size
so one the memory size is large much
larger than past products
two we have a 2x ratio right
640 g of gpu memory
and 2x that on vm memory and that's
because we want to allow for
pre-processing of data
pumping it into the gpu and high
performance for the actual workloads
google's known to be an ai expert we
worked very closely with those people
to ensure optimum performance this
configuration
we didn't stop there we took nvidia's
envy link 3 technology and made gp or
gpu communication
ultra fast that we'll talk a little bit
more about we
continue optionality in the sense that
we allow you to
use network attack storage or bring in
server local ssd storage for faster disk
io
for virtualization we spend a lot of
time saying
how do we get you consistent performance
how do we optimize performance
and how do we make it transparent in the
way that your application
could take best use of this
infrastructure so we've made a lot of
improvements on finuma and pneuma
scheduling
to get those characteristics for you
for scale out workloads we spend a lot
of time on the network stack
you'll see the a2 family comes with two
flavors the high gpu flavor and the
manga gpu flavor
the high gpu flavor goes up to eight
gpus
and 96 cpus that's great if you need a
little bit more pre-processing power
for image recognition or other type of
workloads right with 12
cpus per one gpu also comes with 100
gigabits of network performance so if
you want to scale
out more linearly right the high gpu
is a nice flavor to have
but for the customers who want the
ultimate gpu parallel
performance we have the a2 mega gpu
16 gpus 100 gigabit networking
local ssd hive ram
on both of these two flavors for scale
out workload we spent a lot of time
optimizing the nvidia nickel library if
you just take the
open source out of the box library that
enables
vm to vm communication first is what we
have for an
optimized version of that that we make
available to you
into something we'll explain later
there's a 70
or up to 70 percent speed improvement
for these
network tests and when you're scaling
your workload
to one vm two vms 10 vms 100 vms
and so on and so forth that's really
important
let's look a little deeper on this a2
mega gpu vm instance
so nvidia has delivered these hdx boards
there's eight gpus a100s per board and
there's a high speed
envy link fabric allowing for gpu to gpu
communication on a single hdx
but we've worked closely with nvidia to
provide a server platform
that combines two hdx boards with a very
tightly intercoupled envy link fabric
so now you have 16 gpus with all to all
envelope connectivity
with 9.6 terabytes per second of peak
bandwidth
why that's important is allows you to
couple of things
one allows you to use the 640
g of gpu memory as a unified memory
fabric
through support of the cuda toolsets
also what it does enables you is really
linearly scalable performance
it's the ultimate scaled up box because
of the gpu to gpu connectivity
in terms of scale out again i talked
about the network performance
where you can have multiple of these
systems running together
that makes bert training go very fast or
any type of ml model training
also works very well for a lot of hpc
workloads
in terms of performance of one of these
vms for fp16
10 petaflops are performance in a single
vm
or 20 peta ops for inference these terms
these numbers
maybe are meaningless maybe they mean
something to you but what they mean is
a lot of performance really good tco
for the same amount of budget you can
get a lot more work done
which means a lot more innovation or
enabling you
to focus on the things that matter for
your business
in terms of applications nvidia spend a
lot of time working on
how do i enable more and more with cuda
compute
in our gcp marketplace or via
nvidia's gpu cloud there's pre-packaged
containers
with tons of applications that are ready
to go that have gpu power
you don't need to worry about installing
the drivers or the applications
just get the container run it on google
cloud run it on the a2 or any of our
gpus
for ai workloads we've been talking a
lot about that bottom stack on this
picture
the infrastructure layer we're committed
to providing the best infrastructure no
matter what
no matter what your choice of hardware
is
up above stack if you don't want to
worry about the infrastructure
on gce or in kubernetes engine both
support the new a2 vm
we have the ai platform this is a
managed service offering
it allows you to do ml training as a
service predictions as a service
get quickly start with notebooks you
don't have to manage your capacity pools
or worry about
anything like that just have your data
scientists use the tools that's best for
them
powered by these new vms that i've been
talking about
going up a stack in the layer one more
time if auto ml
this is where you can create custom
models for your business based on your
data but you don't have to know pi
flip torch you don't need to know
tensorflow
you just bring your data let us do the
work for you
or we have a bunch of apis that
developers can just quickly
the development language of their choice
using a series of pre-trained models
things like vision or translation get
started super quickly
all of this is powered again by
world-class infrastructure
including these a2 vms
let's talk a little bit more about
performance improvements
right for real workloads i talked before
about just
how many operations a second can the
thing do but really what matters is the
workload
so for ml training one of the most data
demanding gpu demanding applications
is the burt language model right
teaching a computer how to understand
language
how to have conversations it's a very
popular one right now
and you can see a 3x or a 6x improvement
over the v100 previous generation
we our own internal tests have seen
workloads that have taken about a week
take about a day our customers on our
alpha are reporting
using fp16 real-world scenarios very
close to that 3x
improvement i believe i saw it as a 2.8
last i checked
so these numbers provided by nvidia
we're seeing
real similar things from our customers
on inference again a100 a big step
forward
over v100 t4 is still a great product
but sometimes you want a little bit more
bandwidth on inference
for batch workloads you can use seven of
those gpu partitions to get
a really large amount of inference
workloads and
for some workloads it's not just
inference right
perhaps it's reinforcement learning
right that's using a model
to do game simulations at the same time
training the model as well so both of
these are really important
right for these large scale workloads
so hopefully it should be very clear
why and how the a2vm on gce
is going to be highest performance
and while we haven't announced public
pricing yet trust me it's going to be
the best tco
on google cloud let's talk a little bit
about gpu accelerated apache spark
now what spark is it's a framework it's
a tool set
a lot of data scientists and analysts
use the software
in the old world spark 2 it would be a
cpu
cluster you'd pipe a bunch of data in
you would process that data format it
maybe remove pii information you put in
storage
and then you would have to have another
cluster of configuration hardware
that would do an ml model training or an
hpc job
or run an analysis so nvidia
and google work together to help
speed up that by bringing gpu power
to both model training as well as data
preparation
spark 3 supports both of this through
rapids
and now google's managed service data
proc
right supports spark 30 clusters and
all six of our gpu product offerings
from an infrastructure perspective
i'm really looking forward to seeing how
customers can use
these really large a100 vms right for
data preparation and model training
so we talked a lot about the a100 we
talked about ai and hbc workloads we
talked about performance
it's the newest thing it's very high
demand
it's alpha is available today there's a
sign up form please sign up
but it's not just the only thing we have
we have five other gpus
all doing a wide range of services
whether it be ml training or inference
rendering computations visualization
will have a product to meet your needs
while we have all these and you're happy
and welcome to use any of them
i want to talk about the t4 a little bit
now since launch what we've noticed is
there's a very high demand
for a vm with maybe a variable amount of
cpu and memory
and some gpu compute power and i think
because of that we've seen a lot of
growth more growth than we would expect
both in the inference use case social
media companies
self-driving car simulations batch
workloads real-time streaming workloads
and i want to talk a little bit more
about inference for a second
so gcp thinks the t4 plus our
spread region availability plus our
network
offers a great global low latency
inference product
low latency inference is really
important because a lot of user
experiences
have predictions and ai built into them
whether you're on a mobile app and
you're interacting with ar
right in seeing pictures or if you are
getting ads and you want those ads
specifically recommended to you
or you're using sort of game where the
game has ai intelligence built in
if it's slow and laggy your users aren't
going to want that
so the t4 has ultra low latency for
inference
just one millisecond you combine that
with our global availability of the
product spread around the world
we're going to have capacity close to
the user base of higher populations
and the third major component of this is
our network
i've come from a network background
myself and i'm
very familiar with how networks operate
there's two things that really surprised
me about google's network and why
they'll help here
one just a sheer investment fiber optic
cables points of presence
software-defined networking
this network stack was built right at
first
for ultra low latency that's how do we
get google search
to your web browser as fast as we can
we've added youtube
video streaming and a series of other
services for high bandwidth use cases
that same network that's optimized for
that is what powers google cloud
and one feature specifically the google
cloud default internet networking
connectivity
is could be called cold potato routing
in the sense of
we don't want to get rid of your traffic
and pump it on the internet
as quickly as possible regardless of
packet loss of issues
we optimize how do we do it low latency
how do we connect directly with isps and
let's hold it over our own fiber
and our own networks as long as possible
to that end user
so the combination of those things means
global availability
low latency in the gpus a great network
so a very
high quality user experience for
real-time inference work
let's talk about preemptable gpus in
essence this is our spare capacity
and your cost savings there could be a
lot of reasons why we have spare
capacity maybe we're building ahead of
time before demand
or maybe other users are running batch
workloads that spin up
thousands of gpus at one moment and zero
gpus at the other
but either way there are moments we have
spare capacity
so we make it easy to find that with
kubernetes engine
or a feature i'll talk about next but
what one customer did
is they said how do i use kubernetes
preemptable gpus
and how do i do more with the same so we
were processing
hundreds of thousands of music files and
then went to processing
millions of music files all for the same
budget we made it easy for them
through preample vms and they saved 70
or 80
there is a downside which is you can't
always
guarantee this capacity will be here so
you have to have
flexible completion times in this case
it worked out
there's a blog link in our blog please
go check out
and thank you for the customer story
really appreciate that
to that end i talked about not only
having the best gpus
making it easy making it easy to scale
the previous example was
on kubernetes but perhaps you use vms on
gce
so for a long time we've had managed
instance groups that allow you to scale
up and down gpu capacity or any capacity
we have a new feature that lets you find
spare gpu capacity
called the distribution shape any so
instead of worrying about how much
capacity we have where and working with
our capacity team
just create yourself a managed instance
group set your targeted
region set the targeted quantity of
capacity
and allow us to find those vm's capacity
for you
this is specifically useful in the
preemptible case
right where you know you're only getting
access to our spare capacity
and why not let us find that for you
so i'm excited to see the usage of this
so far
let's talk about another exciting way we
make it easy to get started
and to get high performance the deep
learning environment
when i first started as a product
manager a few years ago in gpus
i do what normal product managers do i
try the product i listen to users
and one of the things way back then i
was surprised to find
how easy it was to use the
infrastructure or create it
but how hard it was for the software so
deep learning environments meant to
solve that
they pre-configured the drivers the
libraries
they pre-configure pi torch or
tensorflow a series of applications
and they package it as vm images or
containers
not only that these put in performance
optimizations like the nickel
library we talked about before easy to
get started
easy to scale up
let's talk a little bit about tensorflow
enterprise
for some customers who perhaps want
enterprise grade support
or just those cloud scale performance
optimizations
these dlvms or containers that we talked
about before
are there for you not only that the
teams worked hard
to get access to tf1 and tf2
supporting the a100 available today
that's not quite available in the open
source tensorflow
so really excited to see that and our
alpha customers already running on
tensorflow one
and two on our a2 vms
and to wrap up today's talk i just want
to show you how simple it is to get
started
with all the things let's say i have a
tensorflow 2
code i want to run or a notebook i
spin up a gcloud command pick the new a2
vm family
size 1 gpu i pick the pre-packaged vm
container
that has everything i needed all the
performance optimizations and software
i hit enter i get infrastructure i
connect to the jupiter notebook
and i get started
i want to thank you for listening to
today and learning about the a2bm
family new on gce with nvidia a100s
we are now in alpha i encourage you to
sign up and get started right away
our public available will be soon thank
you and have a great day